we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to David P
I don't remember when it was yesterday
the day before
I pointed out that when someone said
less it's actually fewer
and now I'm getting attacked as an
intellectual douche
listen to this hey David I was just
listening to your show today and you
like made fun of someone for saying
lesser instead of fewer or less instead
of fewer and I just thought that's kind
of below you you know there's a lot of
really intelligent people out there if
you don't know that that's how you're
supposed to use the word myself included
I'm I'm a very smart educated high IQ
person I believe you didn't know that so
I just think it's kind of a silly thing
to make someone make fun of someone for
and it just makes you seem like you're
being a little bit of an intellectual
douche so okay so listen this is
actually something that it there's a
backstory to this I used to get very
confused with less and fewer and just a
few years ago I was getting crushed for
it in the comments and then now it's
sort of like a joke that I pointed out
when other people do it not being an
intellectual douche not being
condescending very smart people mix that
up all the time I speak English as a
second language it had to be explained
to me in explicit detail let's not take
everything personally and it really
sounds like this guy's saying I see
myself as incredibly smart like my IQ is
really really high and I didn't know
that so therefore it must not be
important you must be making fun of
people let's all relax okay it's fine
it's fine if you were less than okay not
a big deal we have a great bonus show
for you today
a truck crashed near the White House
and a Nazi flag was reportedly found uh
uh outside of the truck which was in the
truck and it is again raising questions
about what is going on here secondly
Ireland is going to start requiring
cancer warnings and calorie counts on
alcoholic alcoholic beverages this is
something many in the U.S have been
advocating for saying listen we put a
lot of this stuff on cigarettes we
should put it on alcohol as well we do
have surgeon general's warnings on
alcohol about pregnant women but some
people want to see more and Ireland is
doing more we will discuss and lastly
Ron DeSantis has created a police
program to lure officers to work as
police in Florida who have violent
records in their pasts why is this being
done does it make any sense is it a good
idea we will deal with all of those
questions and more when producer Pat
joins me on today's bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at joinpakman.com it's cheap
quick and the most direct and important
way to support our program and remember
that if you would like you can get on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com and
Monday morning you'll get an email
telling you how to sign up for
membership at a dramatically discounted
rate that's Monday Memorial Day just get
on my newsletter at davidpackman.com